if you pursue the materialist dream it
doesn't fulfill you you give yourself a
purpose and then the purpose is to get
more and more money and for what uh
whereas if you use that for purposes of
saying I can do something to help others
and that's a really lasting and
important value you're going to benefit
yourself as well as others right because
we've deluded ourselves into believing
that wealth uh will be the thing that
makes us happy but all that evidence
suggests and establishes that Beyond a
certain threshold point it doesn't do
that at all and in fact it is in the
giving that we that we are engendered
with this sense of fulfillment which is
really what we're all kind of after
right so far far be it from being this
you know self-flagellating Pursuit it's
actually self-serving in that regard
while you're also alleviating suffering
and doing all this good in the world